N plus two divided by the quantity three M plus fifteen is correct. Nice work
for getting either of these correct. We'll start by finding the lowest common
denominator for these two fractions. We'll find the common factors for N plus
five. And m plus two. Make sure that you don't put a single m here. They have a
term of m, but they don't have a common factor of m. And it's because we have
addition between each of these terms. Multiplying by the L-C-D divided by the
L-C-D, we can see that the factors that m plus five cancel out. These equal one.
Likewise, in the denominator of the complex fraction M plus 2 divided by m plus
2 equals 1. This leaves us with 3 times m plus 2 for our numerator. And 9 times
m plus 5 for our denominator. We can simplify these numbers, since they're
factors that appear in the numerator and denominator. 3 9ths reduces to 1 3rd.
We just divide each number by 3. Finally we distribute our 3 to get n plus 2
divided by 3m plus 15, our final answer.